okay yesterday on the program I called
out Amy Siskind a self-described
feminist activist because she tweeted
couple days ago that we should not vote
for that she will not vote for any white
or male candidate in 2020 and I pointed
out that's a racist and sexist policy to
say that merely on the basis of race or
sex you're not going to vote for someone
that's bad and I can't get behind that I
got a lot of positive feedback and some
negative here's one example of a
voicemail that liked the fact that I
called this out David I want to commend
you for that video about left-wing
racism and misogyny you are one of the
very few left wing commentators who's
actually honest and called their own
side out when they do something that's
wrong and I wanted to say that I commend
you for that there's one reason why I
listen to yourself
you need to continue to do this because
if you're truly going to be honest you
have to call it out on your side as well
and good job on you for that okay I
appreciate that but it really shouldn't
be notable that there's just some basic
level of objectivity by which when you
see racism or sexism you call it out
without regard to which side it's coming
from now unfortunately things have
really scaled up with this Amy Siskin
thing since I told you about what went
down yesterday she has number one
blocked me on Twitter again understand
that what I did was engage her on
whether preemptively dismissing
candidates on the basis of race and sex
is a good idea for the left she blocked
me on Twitter she called Boston College
where I taught as an adjunct professor a
couple of semesters ago demanded that I
be fired why I don't know and she is
smearing me all over the internet okay
so this stuff can get ugly really
quickly Pat and I know some people are
insisting she's not really on the Left
that she voted for Sarah Palin
McCain in 2008 my understanding is she
just voted on the basis of gender and
that's why she voted for Palin she
started an activism group with 30
Hillary Clinton supporters so we can
argue over whether she's really on the
left or ostensibly on the left or
whatever but the point here is I called
out racism and she's trying to get me
fired this is the mic Serna vicha proach
doesn't sound like she's in too good of
company but it's the approach that she's
taking good thing she can't try to get
you fired as host of the David Pakman
show cuz I don't think that would go
over that well I think it would not I
think that the majority of our audience
would not take too kindly to that I'll
follow up on the latest of next week
we'll give it some time to simmer and
see if anything actually comes of it at
Boston College we've got a great bonus
show for you today we will unfortunately
talk about the fact that it's been a
pretty violent year for journalists and
that the United States is not a
particularly good place when it comes to
violence against journalists we will
talk about self-powered electric
bandages which could speed healing and
we will also talk about how Arizona
voters rejected martha mcsalley
and now she's their senator all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
get the bonus show instantly by becoming
a member at WWJ pakman.com or by
becoming a patron for at least five
bucks a month at patreon.com slash david
pakman show